all right let's uh move to camila harris
on nbc here she is a couple couple clips
here before we get to the to the really
good one we'll start with this
talking about how to find tests
um
and she has an interesting response to
that let's
two years into this
why didn't the administration just go
out and and secure
more at-home tests after the delta surge
in the fall why are we at a point now
where folks still can't get tests
but we just ordered
a
i don't have the number in front of me
but millions of tests we have 20 000
sites
where people can go and i urge people to
you can google it or go on to any search
engine and find out where free testing
and the free testing site is available
but not a vice president the fact that
we're still telling people to google
where you can get a test
but oh but come on now i mean really if
you if you want to figure out how to get
across town to some restaurant you heard
is great you usually do google to figure
out where it is so that's simply about
giving people
right a mechanism by which they can
locate something that they need
something that can help them
did she just say do google you know you
got to do it do the do google
plug it into on the internets you do the
google
what is with she seems to have picked
this up from biden i don't know what it
is with the biome but this is like
infectious i guess where where she does
this thing now too or her primary
argument is come on i mean come on now
come on
of course the answer that she should be
giving to this line of questioning about
tess is that look we don't need uh to
have 100 million tests out there
because if you're not sick you don't
need to be getting tests the whole
reason we're running out of tests this
this is one right i don't blame i
actually don't blame the administration
for this
the fact that there's
some places are running the reason why
some places are running out of tests is
that you get all these these psychotic
people who are hoarding tests when
they're not even sick
that's why we're running out as long as
people are doing that we're going to run
out of tests
but what you should say is it doesn't
matter you don't need a test if you're
not sick live your life
if you are sick stay home
if you have a heat if you have a fever
or whatever that just stay home like you
would any other time
what do you need to test for
that's what she should say but she she
can't say that
because she cannot abandon
the course and abandon this strategy and
speaking of the strategy she was also
asked um
is is the strategy working
i mean we're looking at record levels of
of covet cases right now
doesn't seem to be much indication that
the biden administration strategy is
working so is it time to change course
she's asked and here's what she says
at what point does the administration
say you know what this strategy isn't
working we're going to change strategies
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
my god
i so direct transcript here okay
um i i had trouble i feel like i knew
the aboriginal translator for that one
actually that was that was that's this
is tough to understand so here's what
she said direct transcript verbatim
it's time for us to do what we have been
doing and that time is every day
let's pause on that sentence just for a
second it's time for us to do what we
have been doing
and that time is every day well okay so
i
guess
in a way that makes sense so
whatever we're doing right now
it's it's time for us to be doing that
and so like whatever you're i'm trying
to understand this whatever you're doing
in the present moment
well it's obviously time that you're
doing that and so that time is every day
because you're always living in the
present moment so whatever you're doing
in that moment that's what you're doing
in that moment and that time is every
day all the time
that makes sense no it doesn't make any
sense at all does it uh then she says
okay so it's time for us to do what we
have been doing and that time is every
day
every day it is time for us to agree
that there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
the only part of that that sort of made
sense and is from her perspective is
every day it's time for us to agree
that's really what she wanted to get to
ev you know what it's time for every day
from just agree with me
that's what it's time for
she is so bad at this
she is terrible at this
um
probably the least skilled politician
we've seen at this level
certainly in our lifetimes
i mean there's a reason why democrats
are now thinking about pulling
hillary clinton out of her crypt
i thought she was the least talented
politician
camilla harris makes makes hillary
clinton look
human by comparison makes hillary
clinton look charismatic
and skilled by comparison
she's really making me think that i
could why don't i just run at this point
i always thought no i could never run
for political office because number one
that sounds like
hell on earth to be in that position
it's a lot more fun to complain about
politicians than to be one of them but
also i know that i would be terrible at
it
[Music]
um
but i'd be better than this at least
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated